hi
my name is ryan and this is a
walkthrough of how to get started with
assured workloads in the united states
in the next few minutes we'll walk
through how to set up a new assured
workloads folder in the google cloud
console so you can run regulated
workloads securely on google cloud ready
let's get started
[Music]
as we discussed in the first video
assured workloads is a tool that helps
you run secure and compliant workloads
on google cloud
all organizations have to do is choose
the right regulatory framework and
google cloud will put the necessary
cloud controls in place to make sure
that compliance requirements are met
this helps organizations use the most
innovative cloud services while meeting
strict compliance requirements
surrounding data residency personnel
access and encryption key management
customers may need united states
specific platform security controls u.s
data location and adjudicated u.s
persons to support compliance
requirements assured workloads support
several different platform controls for
united states compliance
these include
u.s regions and support federate
moderate fedramp high
criminal justice information systems
irs publication 1075
dod impact level 4
hipaa and high trust let's take a closer
look at how to get started
first visit the google cloud console at
cloud.google.com
console
before you can set up an assured
workloads environment you must select an
organization
then navigate to the compliance section
the compliance section you can create a
new assured workloads folder or view
existing assured workloads folders
within your organization
for each existing folder you can see its
name creation time compliance type data
region and labels
click create to create a new assured
workloads folder you will first need to
check that you meet the prerequisites
for folder creation
this means having access transparency
enabled for your organization
this provides you an audit trail of
support actions
a parent folder registered using the
provider request form
a premium subscription to assured
workloads if you are looking to use a
compliance type beyond federate moderate
hipaa or high trust
private preview access if you want to
create assured workloads folders with
new controls and geographic expansions
next select the geographic area in which
you are trying to comply with regulatory
requirements
assured workloads offers control in the
eu us and canada today
let's pick united states and click next
assured workloads offers u.s compliance
controls procedures fedramp high
federant moderate hipaa high trust
dod impact level 4 and u.s regions and
support
let's pick u.s regions and support which
offers customers u.s data residency for
at use and at rest in addition to
restricting support to u.s persons
located in the u.s
this control also restricts developers
from deploying non-compliant resources
and creating resources outside of the us
click next
specify the us region you would like to
restrict your workload to
on this step the suggested option is us
which provides access to all u.s regions
this is key to supporting disaster
recovery and multi-regional deployments
of resources applications across the u.s
this is unique google cloud can meet
compliance requirements in all of its us
regions because it does not take a
govcloud approach
click next select the parent folder you
registered earlier as the place where
your new folder will live
this parent folder signals to resources
that a regulatory boundary is set
if you try to choose a folder that is
not registered you will get an error
like this
then give your assured workloads folder
a name
click next the last step is configuring
your key management project and key ring
this will create a separate key
management project within your assured
workloads folder and a key ring in which
to place your keys
the key ring sets you up to utilize
customer managed encryption keys or
externally managed encryption keys
this security guardrail allows you to
protect your keys the same way you
protect your regulated data while
ensuring developers and your environment
are restricted to using keys that meet
the regulatory requirements of your
organization
click next
this brings you to the review section
where you can review compliance type
details folder name and location and
supported products
click create to create the assured
workloads folder
now you will see the new assured
workloads folder in your list
and that's it
from this point forward any folder or
project created inside of this folder
will inherit the guardrails you specify
there are different pricing tiers for
assured workloads depending on your
organization's needs
the free tier includes favorite moderate
platform controls
with the free tier there are no
additional fees to existing products and
services
and it's available to all google cloud
customers via the cloud console and api
beyond the free tier there is the
premium subscription tier which includes
premium us eu and canada platform
controls
the premium subscription is a 20 uplift
applied to only the regulated resources
and assured workload's folders
this requires an active premium support
or enhanced support subscription
organizations can get a premium
subscription via an offline contract
process where the annual regulated
google cloud workload span is estimated
upfront and billed as a fixed fee
subscription so there you have it a
walkthrough of how you can get started
with assured workloads in the united
states to easily run secure and
compliant workloads on google cloud
if you want to learn more visit
cloud.google.com
assured
workloads
and stay tuned for more episodes of
assured workloads 101 where we'll walk
through how to use assured workloads in
europe sieges compliance and how to
build with compliance in mind thanks for
watching
[Music]